Merg să mă schimb imediat și am plecat
direct în căutarea unui nou câștigător.
Campania Ești abonat? Ai câștigat
continuă pe canalul de YouTube Claumar
Pescar. Trebuie doar să te întâlnești cu
mine sau cu unul dintre colegii mei pe
lacul pe care î frecventez pentru că noi
mergem pe toate lacurile din țară. Și
dacă te am găsit și ești abonat la
canalul de YouTube Claumar Pescar
primești un premiu din partea noastră.
Și ce credeți? Premiul de astăzi nu l
voi da singur. Salut! Numele meu e Sami,
vin din partea Clau și am o întrebare
pentru dumneavoastră. Dacă sunteți
abonat la canalul de YouTube Claar
Pescar, avem un premiu pentru
dumneavoastră. Nu uit. Hai, hai să
verificăm. Este valabil și pentru
dumneavoastră?
[Muzică]
Ia să vedem. Cum ar fi să fie amândoi
abonați?
Nu, tu nu ești dă i. Poți să dai abonare
și poate ne mai vedem. Ia să vedem
dumneavoastră.
Ia să
vedem să le spuneți nepoților să vă
descarce YouTube și să l instalați, să
dați urmărire acolo. Poate, cine știe,
ne mai vedem. Fi întinse în continuare.
Vă
salut. Cum merge treaba? Scărie
[Muzică]
aici. Ia uite, mă, dăia lungi, dar e
vălț lungi. Are 45 kg. Și neg așa.
Vai de capul meu. Uite cum a luat
direct. Vă salut, băieți. Salut. Ce
onoare avem noi aice. Fii atent. Vă
salut cu drag. Tot respect, Sami, îmi
pare bine. Salut. A
început. Te salut. Hai că vin imediat. A
început campania. Ești abonat? Ai
câștigat la Claumar Pescar. Suntem. Dacă
ești abonat, primești premiul. Dacă ești
abonat și tu, primești tu un premiu din
partea mea, că tot am vorbit cu
amândouă. Da.
pe YouTube.
Claumar
Pescar, tu nu ești abonat. Dă i acuma
abonare, te
rog, și hai să vedem aici
la
abonat. Deci tu ai încasat azi, cum s ar
zice. Felicitări. Mulțumesc frumos drag
și încă o dată să strâng mâna bine avut
onoarea să nu știu cu mare pescar cu
mare aruncător să zic așa sau nu cu mare
drag mă bucur că v am cunoscut și eu.
Fire întinse în continuare pentru că ne
am găsit fericitul abonat împreună cu
Sami o să mergem să i oferim premiul de
astăzi este vorba de produse în valoare
de 450 RON oferite de clauar
pescar domnul meu, sunteți fericitul
abonat. Vă mulțumesc. Vă felicităm.
Plăcere. Și avem aici produse clauari
pescar în valoare de 450 RON. Doamne,
mulțumesc.
Segetare, matrițe pentru metod, boiles
uri de cârlig, pungi de nadă. Chiar am
și o de la dumneavastră punga de nadă.
Chiar acuma cea apărută nouă. Pete pungi
PVA. Ia uitați croșete, da, agrafe
rapide, tot, tot, tot, tot, tot. În
valoare de 450 RON premiul ăsta al
dumneavoastră. Vă mulțumim că ne
urmăriți și sper să ne mai vedem. Cu
mare drag. Astăzi am fost Sami Energie
și Darius Elisei la Delta dintre sate.
Iar până data viitoare te aștept în
showroom ul din bulevardul Ghencha 30
sau poți să intri să ți faci
cumpărăturile de pe claumarpesc.ro. No.